- He's the host of his own hit CNN show,
United Shades of America.
It's amazing, you should check it out.
Let's welcome W. Kamau Bell.
Hey, what's up Kamau, how you doing?
- Hey, good.
Thanks for having me.
- Did you think, cause here
on the show we want this
to be an active and open forum
for everyone to share their
experiences and thoughts.
But do you think that
what you've been doing is
kind of what's happening right now?
- I think the conversations
that I've been having
on the United Shades,
I've been hearing all my life
from my mom, friends of my mom.
My mom's a single mother,
which means as a kid,
you go everywhere your single mom does
cause she's not paying for babysitters.
Doesn't have the money.
So I was always around a
lot of adult conversations
and I was born a few years
after the civil rights
movement sort of peaked.
So there's a lot of conversations
about what do we do next?
So for me, this is just the conversation
that I was always hearing,
and I feel really honored
that CNN invites me to have them on TV
because me and my friends
have these conversations
all the time, but I know the CNN audience
isn't always having those conversations.
- We're starting the
conversation in our work family.
How have you been starting the
conversation in your family
about George Floyd and the protests?
- Well, you know, because
I worked for the news,
we have the news on all the time.
We just had it on before
I sat down with you,
and my kids ask questions.
I got a nine year old and five-year-old
and they ask questions
about what's going on.
And the thing, I think a lot of people,
especially white people are afraid of is,
I don't want to show my kids the news
cause I don't know how
they'll handle the information
or I don't know what to tell them.
But for me it's like, just
do the same thing you do
with your kid any time.
talk to them and answer the question,
and at some point your
kid will let you know
when they've had enough,
cause they'll be like,
"I don't understand."
Or they'll just walk off
and go do something else.
- Yeah, they just walk away.
It's like an attention span of a gnat.
Yeah, I agree.
So many people that
I've talked to as well,
in the limelight, not in
the limelight, you know,
they're afraid to say the wrong thing.
And sometimes I feel like
that's happened with me.
Like I say something I'm like,
"That is not what I meant
at all. Like, wait, what?"
So what do you say to that?
Cause I don't think people should be quiet
cause that hasn't helped.
But at the same time,
what if they're afraid
that what they're saying
is going to be twisted.
- I'd say don't be afraid
of saying the wrong thing.
Be confident you're going
to say the wrong thing.
You're going to say the wrong thing.
It's the step into saying
the wrong thing boldly.
And the key part is,
when somebody tells you
said the wrong thing, go,
"Oh, did I say the wrong thing?
I'm sorry, what is the right thing?"
Or, "Tell me where I can go find out
what the right thing is and I will learn
to say the right thing."
I think people's fear of
saying the wrong thing again,
white people, it then puts
them in a places where
they never say anything, which
is why we have, you know,
George Floyd obviously
is not the first person
to be killed by a police.
- Breonna Taylor. I mean, we can go on.
- Yeah, there's Tony McDade.
And there's been black
people since George Floyd
who've been killed by
cops under circumstances
that don't make any sense.
But the fact is that I think
for the most part white people,
because they're not
continuing the conversation,
it's like every time
it happens, it's anew.
It's like, "I can't believe
that happened," you know?
- Yeah.
- I think you have to
realize if you had invested
in the conversation, let's
say if your great grandparents
had invested in it during
when Emmett till was murdered,
we wouldn't have to be
having the conversation now.
- Honestly, this whole
conversation is why we've started
the conversation specifically
in our own environment,
because I think sometimes we
start thinking of a problem
and it gets so big.
Like when I think of world hunger,
when I think of Black Lives Matter,
when I think of anything,
I just start going,
"Oh, it's such a big problem,
how are we going to fix it?"
But I think if you focus in
your own small community,
and if everybody does that,
then that's where change can happen.
Because you start focusing,
you start calling your friends
out, calling yourself out,
allowing people to talk
and actually listening,
like you're saying.
And I think that's why we
wanted to start the conversation
with our show and being the
change that we want to see.
And I just want to
thank you because I know
that you've been doing this for years
because I've been one of your viewers.
Well, y'all look for a season five
of Kamau's Emmy winning
show, it's amazing.
United Shades of America
this month on CNN.